Okay.
So that's the coat of many colors.
So it's an estimation of what Joseph is like and what we're seeing with all of
these patriarchal figures is the continual realization of the ideal person,
right?
You could think about it as success of approximations of the ideal person.
And the story is exploring all sorts of different possibilities,
including ones that are very violent and catastrophic and malevolent.
It's,
it's,
it's trying to cover the entire territory and to focus in on what's the proper
way through the maze,
the maze of life,
the labyrinth.
And the hint here is that while you should be multidimensional,
these are the generations of Jacob.
Joseph being 17 years old was feeding the flock with his brother and allowed,
was with the sons of Bilhah and with the sons of Zilpah,
his father's wives.
And Joseph brought unto his father they're evil report.
Well,
we already know that Joseph has Jacob's favorite and so that doesn't make him
very popular among his brothers.
He's younger.
And now we also find out that he's being set up more or less,
as you might say,
a snitch,
because that's what this phrase means is that he goes out and watch us,
his older brothers.
And if they do something they shouldn't do that.
He comes trotting back to Jacob and reports,
well that's not going to make you popular.
So,
and you would say,
well,
is that Joseph's problem
or Jacob's problem.
And I would say,
and this is something I learned from reading dealing too,
is that that's a conspiratorial problem,
right?
Is it's the parents at fault,
but so is the child who agrees to do that.
They've got a little cabal going and you might say,
well,
it's only the parents' fault,
but the sun will be taking advantage of every advantage that offers him.
Because he could say no to.
I won't do that.
So anyways,
so Joseph is the favorite.
He's a bit of a teacher's pet.
That's what it looks like.
Now,
Israel loved Joseph more than all his colors because he was the son of his old
age and he made him a coat of many colors.
And when his brethren saw that their father loved him more than all his
brothers,
they hated him and could not speak peaceably unto him.
So let's say you have a child or number of children and one of them is your
favorite.
How should you treat that child?
Well,
it isn't obvious that you do them any favors by overtly making them be your
favorite,
right?
I mean,
first of all,
maybe you don't challenge them as much as you should.
And second of all,
you definitely set up a cane,
enable like scenario in the household and that,
or maybe it's an edible situation too because you happen to love your child more
than you love your,
your spouse,
which is,
that's not a recipe for familial harmony.
So it's,
it seems to be a bad idea.
Okay.
So now we have two reasons that Joseph is not liked by his brothers is,
one is,
well he's a bit of a rat Fink and the other is that he's the,
he's the favorite and he's playing that to the hilt by the looks of things.
And when his brethren saw that their father loved him more than all his brethren
and all his brothers,
and they hated him and could not speak peaceably unto him,
okay.
And Joseph dreamed a dream and he told it to his brethren and they hated him.
The more.